you are filling up trays to make ice
cubes you notice that each tray holds
the exact same amount of water but has a
different number of ice cubes that it
makes the blue tray makes eight equally
sized ice cubes the pink tray makes 16
equally sized ice cubes so let me draw
the blue tray here
so it makes the blue tray i'll draw it
like this
that is not blue let me draw it
in blue
so the blue tray makes eight
so this is the blue tray right over here
and let me draw it divide it into eight
sections to represent the eight equally
sized ice cubes and i'll try to do it so
let's see that's about in half and then
i'm going to put each of those in half
and then each of those in half so
there we go so this is pretty close
this is pretty close to eight equally
sized cubes except for this one there
let me actually make it a little bit
cleaner so
there's like the half
half
half half
all right so this is looking a little
bit better so eight equally sized ice
cubes this is the blue tray now the pink
tray takes the same amount of water so
i'm gonna make it the exact same length
so the pink tray is the exact same
length
but it has 16 equally sized ice cubes so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make these same sections here
but then i'm going to cut these sections
in two
so
that's eight and to 16 i got to divide
these into two
so
almost done
this is the hard part that last one
wasn't that neat
almost done all right
there we go set up the problem
now you put three ice cubes from the
blue tray into your drink
so let's do that so one
two
three
ice cubes from the blue train to your
drink how many ice cubes from the pink
tray would you need to equal the same
exact amount of ice
so there's a bunch of ways to do it we
can think about it with numbers or we
think about it visually let's first
think about it with numbers so how much
of this tray have i pulled out
well i have eight equally
equally sized cubes and i took three of
them out so this literally represents
three-eighths
three
over eight
so the question is three
over eight if i take three out of eight
equally sized cubes that's the same
quantity as taking what
i want to do that in white that's the
same quantity as taking
how many cubes out of 16
out of 16 equally sized cubes
well let's look at it over here visually
so if we want the exact same amount of
ice so we're going to have one
two
three
four
five six
we have six over sixteen so this is
equal to 6 over 16.
6 over 16. now does that make actual
sense
well sure when to go from 3 over 8 to 6
over 16 you multiply the numerator by 2
and you multiply the denominator by 2.
now does that actually make sense
well sure it does because for the for
the pink ice tray
you have two ice cubes for every one
that you have in the blue ice tray so
the blue ice tray you have eight equally
sized cubes well for each of those
you're going to have two at the pink ice
tray so you multiply by two to have 16
equally sized cubes
and out of the blue tray if you take
three well that equivalent amount for
each of those cubes you would get two
from the pink ice tray so you're
multiplying by two right over there so
the answer the question how many ice
cubes from the pink tray would you need
to equal the same amount of ice well
that is you would need six cubes